[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So
today we are going
to do something interesting.
We are going to deep dive
into something, come back out,
go back to the
basics, and then you
get to question the
people who built
some of the technologies
I'm going to show you.
So I have the easy job today.
So we'll see how that goes.
So let's start thinking
about some of the trends
that some of you are seeing
in your own networks--
so they're for
your own services.
One of our cloud customers, for
example, their entire service
was a single monolith.
And it used to take
them about three months
to ship out a single change.
And what they did is
they took this monolith
and they chopped it up into
about 80 microservices,
and the time to
release something
went down from three
months to a week.
So it's not that people
care about microservices
or they care about all of these
technologies, what they really
care about is what
it brings them.
The second trend, which you
probably already noticed or are
facing based on whatever
deployments and services
that you have, is that hybrid
multicloud, and public cloud,
and Google Cloud
are here to stay.
And this could be simply because
you're migrating to the cloud,
you're not going to make
the migration in one shot,
or it may be that you
want to actually keep
some of these systems on-prem.
And then in the
third case, it could
be that you want to leverage
the best of every public cloud
in whatever they have to offer,
and so you may be deploying
services on-prem or in a
private cloud, in Google Cloud,
and in another cloud.
So the thing that we have
been thinking long and hard
this last year is how
can we make it easy
for you to go deliver hybrid
and multicloud services.
We are literally not toiling
over the infrastructure that's
actually needed to
make this happen.
The first thing
that's actually needed
to make this is to remove
like, look at your service.
You're essentially crafting each
service piece by piece today.
And the first thing
that you want to do
is remove all of the common
core out of your service.
This would be typically
networking code which
involves load balancing,
or there's fault injection,
or failure recovery.
It depends on what all you're
adding to your services.
So what if we
removed all of this
and then encapsulated it
into a simple component
that you could just
add to your services
without bothering
to write in all
of these primitives inside
your services themselves?
And then the second
thing is, once you've
done that, who's going to go
manage all of these services.
And that is where
you need services
management infrastructure.
And it's basically not something
you want to manage yourself.
So you want a fully
managed services
management infrastructure.
So I thought, let's
do something fun.
Let's actually go and build
out, let's say a summer shop,
because it's pretty hot-- not in
San Francisco, but other ways.
And if you think of a
typical web-facing app,
you'd have a front-end,
and you'd likely
have a shopping
cart service, which
is along with your catalog.
And then you would have
some sort of a payment
gateway or a payment system.
So let's call this
our summer shop,
and we have three services.
Typically our
user's traffic would
go in that order, which is
user to front-end to shopping
to payment.
Now, one of the nice
things that have actually
come to the forefront, I
would say, in the last one
year, or probably a
little bit more than that,
is this concept
of a Service Mesh.
And you will hear us talking
about it a bit more as we
go throughout the session.
But if you had to think of
Service Mesh, in a very simple
way it's like this--
imagine your infrastructure
that existed,
let's say, 10 years
ago, everything used
to be a one box in project.
Now, you're doing the same
that services, everything
is bundled together.
So what Service
Mesh is trying to do
is actually decouple that.
So if you look at your, let's
say it's a part of a VM.
And on there, all you want
to do is, on your end,
you just want to write
the service software.
And what you want
somebody else to do
is write all of the
common software which
would be load balancing,
which would be, let's say,
service authentication.
Maybe you are doing some sort of
testing, so timeouts, retries--
all of the failure
recovery mechanisms.
So that's what you see on the
bottom half of the Service
Mesh.
What you see, a very
critical component
of this as a service
proxy, which we'll
talk about a bit more.
That's essentially doing
a lot of the heavy lifting
of whatever your
services are doing today.
The service part of it is simply
your either application logic
or your business logic,
and then the green thing
that you see at the top is your
Service Mesh Control plane.
And this is the thing that's
going to talk to your proxies.
This is the thing that's
going to deliver intelligence
to your proxies.
This is the thing that's
going to absorb things
related to observability.
So if you had something like
this, as you can imagine,
the green box is all you need
to focus on, and the rest of it
is taken care of by
your services management
infrastructure.
Now, this is where
Envoy comes in.
And we are really fortunate to
have Matt Klein from Lyft here.
We will ask him all the
tough questions later.
But the Envoy proxy is
actually a very key part
of this infrastructure.
And if you think of
this service proxy
that you saw on
the previous slide,
it's basically Enboy that
fulfills that function in here.
So we use Envoy in addition
to all of the technologies
that we already have, which is
our Compute Engine, Kubernetes
Engine, you've heard
of GKE on-prem,
and then there's our
cloud load balancing.
So if you took a
closer look at Envoy,
what is it that you see inside?
Basically, first of all
this was developed by Lyft.
And it is also battle
tested at Lyft,
so it's already
a hardened proxy.
And the piece that we really
like about Envoy, first of all,
it is high performance
native call implementation.
Then it also provides eventually
consistent service discovery.
And we we'll ask Matt
why that's important.
Then it's also API driven,
which was really important to us
because we almost view it
as an integral part of our,
as you saw, the Service Mesh
and then the service management
story.
And it had to be API-driven
for that to be effective.
It's also extensible with
this notion of filters.
I'm sure Matt will
touch on it a bit more.
One of the nice
things is that several
of these protocols, such as
HTTP/2 are built into Envoy.
So it supports them
from the get-go.
So that's again
important, because that's
what helps you bring in
some of the modernization
into whichever services
that you have to do.
And the most
important thing is, it
was designed for observability.
A lot of times all of
us add in observability
as an afterthought.
And I think that is why a lot
of our services are these silos,
and we really don't
get an end-to-end view.
So if you think about
all of this-- now,
this is what it would
look like if we added
the proxy into our services.
And you can see that now each
of each of our services, these
are either VMs or
containers, whatever
your favorite stuff is.
And then we added
a service proxy
on each of those
instances that's
running each of those services.
Now, this is the cool part.
So we are really excited to
announce Traffic Director.
Traffic Director
is a new service
which is going to take away
some of the toil of going
and managing all
of these services.
So like I said before, what
you really want to focus on
is your either application
logic or your business logic,
and you want Google
to basically take
care of the rest-- google
and then the service proxy.
And so that is where we're
going with all of this.
So this is now
available in alpha.
You are the first people who
are actually hearing about it.
So what exactly is it?
First of all, it's a
GCP-managed service.
Then you can think of it almost
as an enterprise ready control
plane for all of the service
proxies we spoke about.
And the nice thing is that
you had a Service Mesh which
could extend to a
zone, we are going
to let you extend your
Service Mesh across regions.
So you are very used to
our global load balancing
with a single [INAUDIBLE].
Imagine that you brought that
same concept to microservices,
and then you have the
same things that you
get with global load
balancing as you
get with our external one.
The other nice thing is
that Traffic Director
will also health check all of
your proxies for you, which
means each proxy doesn't need
to health check each other.
So you have [INAUDIBLE] square
health checking problem,
and you've just
simplified and outsource
that to the Traffic Director.
So I would say the
two main things
that you want to think about
are global load balancing,
health checking
at scale, and then
the third thing is auto
scaling, which is typically
available for all
of our services.
So based on traffic signals
this will go and actually
scaling back-ends
as well, whichever
ones are running the service.
So if we add a Traffic Detector,
that is where it will go to.
One of the things that
we really wanted to do
was to use open API
between the Traffic
Director and the service proxy.
And so we use the
exteriors, we do APIs.
And we'll talk
about those as well.
And then if you look
at this picture,
essentially the green
box is managed by us,
and then the proxy
is the one that's
taking all of your
networking code.
And then it's sitting next to
your application or business
logic and making things
much, much simpler for you.
So I spoke a little bit
about global load balancing.
And what does that
exactly look like?
So this is what we are
going to go and look at,
which is the service
that we spoke about.
I have three services--
the web front-end,
the shopping cart,
and the payment.
If you can see the first
block, that is, essentially,
your web front-end.
And these are not
two separate things--
one sitting in Singapore region,
and one sitting somewhere
in the US--
this is actually one service
with just instances sitting
in these two different regions.
Same for shopping cart, and
then same for the last service,
which is payment.
So what did we do so far?
We put in a proxy, we
put in Traffic Director.
And the moment we put
in Traffic Director,
we could go expand our service
beyond a single region.
Otherwise, if you
did it on your own,
you would pretty much
be in a single region.
But Traffic Director
enables you to go
and then spillover, or even
failover across regions.
So, I thought, let's take a
quick look at a live setup.
I'm going to ask our folks
to switch me to the demo.
And we will also pray
to the demo gods.
Can you-- OK.
So this is, essentially,
our summer shop.
And we have got some interesting
things that we want to sell,
including, I just
noticed this morning,
a very expensive popsicle,
which costs 300 bucks.
But what you're seeing here
really is that, remember,
we talked about
the three services?
And the first service is the
one that is in US central.
This is our front-end service.
Now, let's try and let's buy
the expensive popsicle now
that we talked about it.
So if you now click this
one, and what you notice
is there's this small blob here
which is a little bit cut off,
but that's our
shopping cart service.
Again, the instances here
are the ones in US central.
And the reason is
because I'm right here.
And our other set of
instances were in Singapore,
so obviously the instances in
US Central, which is in Iowa,
are closer to me.
And then, obviously, we have
a lot of money to spend.
So let's go by
the $300 popsicle.
And what you will notice
is that the payment
service that it
went to is actually
this us-central1-c as well.
So if you go back to
the diagram I just
showed you before,
and let me show
you the back-end of this a bit.
Now, one of the things
about the way we set up is--
let's go back in here.
So these are all
the instance groups.
These are literally the
managed instance groups
running each of your services.
So what you're seeing in here,
essentially, is the first thing
that you would see is
our front-end, which
is two instance groups.
And the second
thing, you would see
our cart, which is two instance
groups, one in each region.
And then the third thing
would be our payment--
again, one in each region.
And the last thing
is simply because I
want to masquerade as a
client from Singapore--
so that's just one
setting in there.
But what you would
really want to look at,
is go to network
services and then
look at you load balancing,
and this is where
you would see three services.
And if we go actually
to the back-ends,
you can see that this is
the front-end service,
then the biggest one is
the shopping cart service,
and then the last one
is the payment service.
So this is what it looked
like when you were actually
accessing it from here.
And then the last thing
that we would want to do--
we can try it live and see.
So I wanted to literally
do everything from scratch.
So this service now,
this is basically
a client that's going
to sit in Singapore.
And-- so maybe
it's not connected.
So there is a client that's
sitting in Singapore.
And what we really
want to see in here is,
would the client in Singapore
actually go in there?
And we'll see if it
wants to go there or not.
If not, we'll see
it on the console.
So I think that might be
because it's their setup.
But let's go back and
take a look at this one.
So I wanted to actually
take you back again
to when we in the summer shop,
if you looked at this one here.
What you can see in here
is these instances--
the payment in South Asia.
So when we come in as a
client from South Asia,
you would go back and first hit
the front-end in South Asia,
and then you would hit the
shopping cart in South Asia,
payment service in South Asia.
So I wanted to switch
back to the slides,
because I wanted to show
what that would look like.
Can we get the slides back?
OK.
So why is that important?
And the reason it
is important is
for this reason, which is if
something were to happen to,
let's say, all of your
instances in the middle region,
if something were
to happen to that,
your first service can
actually go and failover
to the shopping
cart that's actually
deployed in the second region.
And then let's say
there is something
that happens with the shopping
cart service in that region,
because, for instance, it's
just not able to scale up.
Then it would go and it
can access the service
that's in the other region.
So just like you're used to
global load balancing, which
is available for
external services,
you get the same capabilities
with Traffic Director
for your own internal
services as well.
And this is some of the other
config that I abstracted out.
You generally won't have
to configure all of this
by the time you folks
get to using this.
But this is some under the
hood configuration, where
you essentially set up Traffic
Director for your services,
and then you also went, and
if you see at the bottom
you can see Envoy is
running on an instance.
So this is just a snip of
one of those instances.
So we spoke about all
of this, and now we're
going to speak about
something that you
have been hearing throughout
this conference, which
is Istio.
And if you look
closely at Istio--
I think all of you
are mostly going
to be familiar with Istio--
what you get is
service discovery,
you get security
instrumentation,
you get client-side
load balancing.
For those of us who have come
from the traditional load
balancing world, it
is a bit of a change
because you're always used to
the server-side doing the load
balancing, and here you
have the client-side
that has the intelligence
to pick the right back-end.
And then, of course,
you have things
such as circuit
breaking, and you've
got dynamic routing,
and so on and so forth.
Again, building on the
theme of observability,
you can do observability
end-to-end using Istio.
And then you obviously
have mTLS-based security
and several of
the other features
that you'll hear talked
about in these sessions.
One of the nice
things about Istio
is that you can use it
with Kubernetes or GKE,
but you can also
use it with VMs.
So as you go transition
your infrastructure,
you can actually also go and
use it as a migration tool.
So you could pretty much
set this up with your VMs.
And then as you chop
up your monolith--
so as you containerize
your services--
you could just move
them piece by piece.
And then the other
thing is, this
is what Istio an Envoy
look like together.
So same model, there's
a control plane,
there's a data plane, which
is with service A, service
B, and then the proxy there.
So typically, we
use Envoy proxy,
but any XDS with your
compliant proxy can be used.
Now, if you just
imagine this picture,
and you put Traffic Director in
the mix, what you will notice
is this, that
whatever capabilities
you get out of pilot, you can
put Traffic Director there.
And that is one of
the main reasons
we chose to keep the
interface between Traffic
Director and the proxies
using open source APIs.
Because in the
future, you will be
able to just go substitute
your open source pilot using
the Traffic Director.
And then, if there is one
takeaway you probably took away
from this conference, it's
that Google and Google
Cloud are all-in on hybrid.
And so we want your
hybrid services
to get the same benefits that
any of your GCP services get,
which is specifically as it
relates to services management
infrastructure.
And so we want to provide
Traffic Director such
that it can not only
manage the proxies,
and talk to the proxies,
and provide global load
balancing for things in Google
Cloud, but also for things
on-prem.
And then this is the
picture you probably
saw on the keynote day, which
is bringing all of these pieces
together.
And this is how Traffic
Director, Envoy, and then
some our existing technologies,
such as multi-cluster Ingress,
which under the hood has
our global load balancer.
All of these fit in together.
Because at the end of the
day, what you really need
is not point products
that you stitch together.
You need a whole suite of
products, or rather a platform,
that can help you go
and build whatever
services you want to
build, whether it's
on VMs, whether it's on
containers, whether it's
on-prem in GCP and other cloud.
You should be able to do
it the same way with ease
in a way that takes away
all the toil from your end.
So I took you through a
whirlwind tour of all of this.
I now want to start with
where this all began.
And so, please join
me in welcoming
Anna Verenberg from Google,
and Matt Klein from Lyft,
who I get the pleasure of asking
really difficult questions.
After our talk, they will
be available outside to talk
to you, so feel free to
bring in your questions.
And I also wanted to
give a special shout out
to the people who helped
me build these questions.
These are all crowdsourced.
So I'm going to probably
take one of these.
Do you folks have a mic?
OK, I'll take this one.
So let's start with the most
popular question I got asked.
So maybe let's start with Matt.
Matt, why don't you
tell us about yourself.
But the popular
question was not that--
it was, tell everybody one thing
that they don't know about you.
MATT KLEIN: OK.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for having me.
I'm Matt, obviously.
I've been Lyft for
about 3 and 1/2 years,
where I work on networking.
Prior to Lyft I worked at
Twitter, also in networking.
Before that, I worked
at Amazon on EC2.
So I've been working
in the infrastructure
space for over 10 years.
Let's see, one thing that
people don't know about me.
I have a very unhealthy
obsession with pickles.
And I've been known to eat
so many pickles that then I
have to go drink
a bunch of water
because I have like
a salt overdose.
So don't give me pickles.
ANNA BERENBERG: Hi, my
name is Anna Berenberg,
and I've been a software
engineer for 27 years.
In the last 20 years plus,
I work in the networking
industry, and I never wrote
a line of networking code.
I always had interest in
building fault tolerant,
high availability
distributed systems,
and process management, system
management, stuff like that.
And then I joined Google
12 and 1/2 years ago
and spent the last nine
years in infrastructure
and technical infrastructure.
And without moving my
dust, I moved into cloud
three years ago, becoming
responsible for all cloud load
balancing and Google
load balancing products.
One thing people
don't know about me,
I used to dance professionally
ballroom dancing.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: We might have
time for that at the end.
[LAUGHTER]
And you guys have the mic, OK.
So actually this
question is for you Matt.
Let's start with you,
because I generally
assume that most people
would know about Envoy
and what the journey was.
But what we really wanted
to do was, a lot of people
were very interested in hearing
the journey in your own words.
So how did Envoy start, and
what were the exact problems
you were trying to solve?
How did it all begin?
MATT KLEIN: Sure.
So I've been working on
service architectures
for quite some time, like I
was saying, over 10 years now.
So I've seen how Amazon
had kind of solved
these different problems
that people are facing,
how it had been done
over at Twitter,
and I think what I mostly tell
people is most people that
are rolling out microservice
architectures, it sounds great,
we're obviously
told to go and do it
for all of the human
scaling benefits,
but we sometimes gloss over
all the complexities that
come from actually doing that.
So I think a lot of smaller
companies that aren't Google,
they go and they start to roll
out microservice architectures,
and they wind up in
a situation where
they might get 10
or 20 services,
and then things start
getting really difficult,
because they're facing
common problems in networking
with observability.
And what we found
at Lyft, which is
what I think a lot
of companies face,
is that they go
from their model,
and if they start rolling
out microservices,
and then the developers don't
trust the actual microservice
platform.
And you wind up in this
horrible situation where
you have services that people
don't trust because they
can't debug them, they don't
understand what's going on.
And then they start adding
code to their monolith again.
So you're in you're in
this awful situation
of having services that
people don't want to use
and continuing to actually
use your monolith.
So the way that people
have historically
solved this problem
is using libraries.
So at Twitter there was
a library called Finagle.
Google obviously has a
library called Stubby.
And there's other companies
that have solved this.
And that library does a
bunch of common concerns
around things like
observability,
load balancing,
retries, timeouts.
But the industry has moved
to a polyglot architecture.
And by that, I mean
that the days of Java
only are basically over.
So people now are building
services in five, six, seven,
eight different languages.
So building a library in those
eight different languages
that your company has to
support is kind of a nonstarter.
So when I joined
Lyft, Lyft was having
all of these typical
problems around networking,
observability, load
balancing, this kind
of aborted microservice rollout.
And I knew that we could
do a better solution.
And that was this out of
process proxy system where
we could put all of the
complicated logic in there
and provide that for every
application language.
And it kind of grew from there.
It became very popular at Lyft.
It was solving a lot
of business problems.
And we open sourced Envoy
about two years ago,
and nowhere in my
wildest dreams would
I have imagined that I'd
be sitting here right now
and we'd be announcing
these products.
It's been pretty incredible.
But envoy has been sweeping
across the industry,
so there's been a
lot of other folks
that have had common problems.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So did you
just decide to open source it?
Was there any big agenda?
MATT KLEIN: There's
no big agenda.
But to be totally honest, this
is kind of the second time
that I've built Envoy, at
least to a certain degree.
We did something
similar back at Twitter.
And I don't want to
build this again.
[LAUGHTER]
So two times is enough.
Yeah.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI:
That's a good reason.
So Matt, you bring
a lot of expertise
as you built out
Envoy and so on.
I know Anna personally,
because I work with her
on a day-to-day
basis, and I've seen
her do something similar as it
relates to services at Google.
And maybe, Anna, I think what
would be nice is if you can--
you've been there at
Google for 12 plus years,
and some of the experiences that
you had building out services.
But then also about Istio--
how did we decide to open
Istio and how does it
fit in with Kubernetes and
several of our other services
as well?
ANNA BERENBERG: So building,
I worked in the last 12 years
actually.
I wanted to work
on Gmail, instead
I got assigned to group
doing load balancing.
And I thought, fine,
I'll do one year
and I'll go do something else.
I'm still there.
Why?
Because it's such a
fascinating problem.
The way we solved
it at Google, it's
actually a control system that
does a pretty sophisticated
service that does global
load balancing in a way that
improves quality of life for
the services we build for.
For example, how do you
protect against query of death?
How do you figure out that not
all queries or requests add
the same cost,
because some queries
are more expensive than others?
How do you make sure your
back-ends will never overload?
All of that needs to
be thought through so
that services developers
don't have to.
And they don't have to build
some sophisticated solution.
All they have to do is worry
about the business logic.
So with all of that,
my focus has always
been on the control
side of load balancing.
And so, when I saw
Matt's Envoy proxy,
I realized that this is exactly
the proxy I wanted to have.
Why?
Because it's API-drive.
And it's funny, it
had very similar APIs
to the APIs we had internally
at Google between the control
plane system which does
global load dancing
and the proxies themselves.
So with that, when the
idea of Istio came out--
sorry-- and Traffic Director--
thank you-- became a natural
substitution for a pilot
because, with the same APIs
now, we can build into Istio
and make Istio available
not only within a single GKE
cluster, but make it horizontal
and make it available
across the whole GCP, and
on-prem and multicloud.
And in multicloud, when we talk
about global load balancing,
first we were talking
about Google services,
then we started talking global
load balancing within a GCP.
And now, when we
are saying global,
it means really global,
worldwide no matter where.
That's where our aspiration is.
Today we don't
have it, but that's
where we are going with it.
We're going to take
Traffic Director
and make it load balance
anything, anywhere
within an Istio
environment, or actually
within an Envoy environment.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Sounds good.
[LAUGHTER]
So actually, coming
back to you Matt,
i just brushed through a lot
of technical details of Envoy.
I think a lot of people may
not be familiar with things
such as filters, or I
know that observability
is built into Envoy.
Can you describe, let's
say, your top five features
for which you see all
your users using Envoy?
MATT KLEIN: Sure.
Yeah, I think that's a
common question recently,
which is why has Envoy
become so popular?
I think there's a couple
of different reasons.
I think the API is probably
the number one reason.
Actually, when I look
at, for my opinion,
one of the biggest
technology successes
I've seen in the last couple
of years, it's actually Proto3.
Proto3, in my m has
been pretty awesome,
just in the sense
that the ability
to go from a structured IDL to
JSON YAML and back and forth.
And that's how we do our
new configuration now.
So the API is the
same as the config,
and it's super seamless.
You can use GRPC in
a different language,
you can write config
files in YAML and JSON,
and it all works the same way.
And I think people
really love that.
So the fact that you
can control Envoy either
through local config files
or you can serve everything
over a central management
server, it's super flexible.
So, I think, historically, with
proxies like NGINX and HAProxy,
where people have had to
ship around config files--
and that works fine, but
at large scale trying
to manage those files, and make
sure the updates take place,
and kind of figure
out how to do that
from a deployment perspective
can be quite complicated.
So the API has
been very flexible
and has been super popular.
The other thing is the
extension capabilities.
So when I first designed
Envoy, I kind of
based it on prior experience.
And instead of making
it very HTTP-specific,
I built it in a way where
it was an L3, L4 proxy.
So basically,
bytes in bytes out.
And that means that it could
be used for other protocols.
So at Lyft today we use it for
MongoDB, we use it for Redis.
There's people now building
thrift support, mySQL,
we'll do Kafka eventually.
And what you'll
find is that even
in all of these protocol
implementations,
there's a lot of common
core stuff around service
discovery, health checking.
So lots of common
functionality can be shared,
and then you can build
these protocols on top.
And then we also allow
extensions at the HTTP layer,
at the stats layer,
at the tracing layer.
So it's a pretty
rich platform from
an extensibility perspective.
So I think from a
technology perspective,
those are the two main reasons.
A third reason is just from
a developer-productivity
perspective, I'll
be honest in saying
that we're the first open source
proxy where we're on GitHub,
we do CI, we have a
very open community.
So I think people
have really loved
the fact that we're very easy to
engage with and get patches in.
So I think those are
the big three reasons.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: And Anna,
it is similar to how Matt
did a little bit of deep dive
into some of the features,
can you, whenever we say, oh,
we have global load balancing,
for a lot of people it's
this vision of a box--
like a global box-- which is
thread like this huge thing.
I know it's not that at all.
Can you describe a
little bit about,
what is this Traffic Director
thing under the hood?
What does the
architecture look like?
ANNA BERENBERG: So if you
think about Traffic Director it
has two interfaces, one
interface to the proxy,
and it's open XDS APIs.
And they have several
APIs in them--
cluster discovery service,
endpoint discovery service,
listener discovery service,
route discovery service,
health discovery
service eventually,
load reporting service,
secret discovery service.
I'm running it.
So basically it's
all the communication
that needs to happen between
the proxy and the control plane.
Now, on the backside,
Traffic Director
has interfaces to
Google systems--
our proprietary
systems-- that actually
do all that functionality.
We have a control system that
has global load balancing
in a way that there is
nothing in the industry where
we actually load balance based
on a capacity of the back-end.
So we don't do spray and pray,
we actually count the queries.
And so we will never deliver
more than the customer wanted
us to deliver.
And then we have autoscale.
For example, based
on that capacity.
So in addition, we do
centralized health checking.
So what is centralized
health checking?
When I joined Google, one
of the biggest consumers
in Google cluster was
a health checking,
because when the
deployments get big,
if you start doing
[INAUDIBLE] health checking,
the bandwidth consumed by
health checks is enormous.
So all of that sounds like,
eh, that's not the problem.
It actually becomes very boring.
Boring health checking
becomes a massive problem,
because it consumes
all of your network.
So centralized health
checking allows you
to dedicate health
checker and health check
all back-ends in a way that
it's actually trust the result.
The results are getting
merged and aggregated
by control plane.
And then they are distributed
with endpoint discovery
service.
Same with auto scaling--
we take all that data reported
through load reporting service,
and we digest it, and we
translate it into the demand
that autoscaler
needs to get out.
And we integrate
it with autoscaler,
and the autoscaler scales
up based on traffic demand.
And the funny thing that I was
telling Matt, our internal API
is actually matched very
closely to the Envoy APIs,
and that persuaded me that
that's the right proxy to use.
MATT KLEIN: Yeah.
I think that, when
most companies look
at deploying a proxy, like
Envoy, or like HAProxy,
or NGINX, most companies
start with a fairly simplistic
control plane.
And if you even look at
what Lyft does compared
to what Google
does, it's obviously
a totally different
magnitude of scale.
So it's not surprising that
we do things in a far less
sophisticated way.
But what I'm so excited about,
just this whole general area,
is that because of this open
API, and the fact that people
are converging on this API, it
will allow companies like Lyft,
eventually, who, frankly,
are not going to be able
or really can justify
building a control plane as
sophisticated as what
Google can offer,
we can just go and use
that control plane.
And I think there's tons
of companies out there
that would benefit from
this type of technology.
And from a Lyft perspective, we
can still run our own Envoys,
and still manage them, and
still do what we want with them,
but we can get far more
sophisticated functionality
from a health
checking perspective,
from a subsetting perspective,
than we would ever
be able to build ourselves.
So that's super exciting.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: That's awesome.
While both of you
are speaking, you
were talking about Google
and Lyft, a lot of people
hear have their own deployments,
which likely are on-prem.
Many of you are moving
or have moved to GCP.
And a lot of your services
are probably in VMs,
but you do want to containerize
them to get all the benefits.
And then in all
of this, we added
things like on Envoy proxy,
Istio, Traffic Director.
So for people who are
starting out here,
at least based on your
experience with your users,
how do people bring in
these new technologies
into brownfield or
existing deployments?
MATT KLEIN: That's tough.
And it really depends on
the particular deployment.
I think what's interesting
from an Envoy perspective,
is that there is such a
rich ecosystem of projects
that are kind of starting
to be built on top.
So obviously, Istio
is super well-known,
there's a bunch
of other companies
that are building stuff on top.
So kind of what I tell
people these days,
at least from an Envoy or
from a proxy perspective,
is that I would not recommend
that companies go and build
their own control plane.
I think, at this point, people
should be looking at Istio,
looking at pilot, looking
at other solutions that
are out there, just
because I think
people underestimate the
complexity of building
your own control plane.
I think people look at
it, and they're like, oh,
how hard can it be?
I can get some host information,
and send it to Envoy,
and things will just work.
And it does do that
in the beginning,
but then as you start
scaling up and you
deal with the [INAUDIBLE]
health checking problem,
and you deal with security,
and service manifests, and all
this other stuff, it gets
complicated really quick.
So I think my
recommendation, right now
for people that are looking
into these solutions,
is to not necessarily even
look at Envoy directly,
but to look at some of
the stuff that people
are building on top.
And one of the things
I've been saying recently,
and I really firmly
believe, is that it's
really amazing the Envoy
has become so popular
and it's getting very wide
uptake, but at the same time,
I think that in a couple of
years though Envoy will be used
in a lot of places, I
think most people won't
know that they're using Envoy.
I think they're going to consume
it as part of other products
or other systems.
So I would definitely
encourage folks
to look at some of the systems
that are being built on top.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI:
Anna, what about you?
What do you think--
I mean, we hear
this all the time
if you have customers coming
in with existing deployments.
And let's say it's
somebody who is
running their service in a VM.
How would you ask them to start?
Or where would they start?
ANNA BERENBERG: So
from our perspective,
the configuration coming
to Traffic Director
is done via GCP API.
And in the future, we will
add additional Istio APIs.
But GCP API is
already integrated--
those are load balancing
APIs, you provision other load
balancing product.
And what we have done, we
use the same data model
to provision Traffic
Director and Envoys.
The only difference
is one boolean.
And so, in my mind, one, if
you're already using GCP,
it's easier to
add-on, because it's
just you add one boolean
and instantiation of Envoy.
Also, because it's
all integrated,
Traffic Director essentially
becomes a centralized brain
for all your
[INAUDIBLE] everywhere.
So whether you're configuring
Envoy, which is self-managed,
or maybe manager, or
some other product that
is going to be using Envoy, or
for that intent and purposes,
any proxy that's
using the same APIs,
we can extend your
existing deployment
to Istio or to just Envoy.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Sounds good.
I actually wanted to give--
because we want
to hear from you,
so I'm going to give you
this hypothetical scenario.
Let's think, let's say
three years down the line.
I don't like five years.
We'll go with three years.
Would we be talking so
much about pinpoints
of delivering hybrid services?
Or do you think they'll be a
slew of products and platforms,
with this being a
beginning, where
it's just natural to have
something that's across clouds?
How do you see the world,
maybe three years from now--
what kind of products,
technologies,
what is the next thing you
will be working on that
will help some of this stuff?
MATT KLEIN: So from a
three-year perspective,
that's tough to say.
But I'll talk a little
more I think in the 5
to 10-year timeframe,
just in the sense
that I'm a big believer in
serverless technologies.
Serverless just in the sense
that I think most application
developers, they want
to write business logic.
They don't want to worry
about infrastructure.
And the biggest thing that I
see in the industry right now
is that most companies
are spending too much time
on a per developer basis
worrying about infrastructure,
worrying about how networking
works, or observability,
or databases.
So I'm a big believer in the
idea of eventually people
writing functions
or code snippets
and eventually being
able to just ship those.
With that said, I think we're
very, very far from there,
just because I think a
lot of those technologies,
they're orders of
magnitude more complicated
than what we have today.
There's just there's
more auto scaling,
there's more networking, there's
more problems that can happen.
So where I see
things going is, I
think that, increasingly
all of the cloud
providers, not just
Google, are going
to start offering more
integrated products, where
you might not call
it serverless--
it might be container-based.
But the idea is that
people are going
to expect a certain
set of technologies
around observability, service
discovery, load balancing, rate
limiting, policy, RBAC.
And instead of having to worry
about how it's implemented,
people just want to
show up, and say,
I'm going to use these features.
So I'm biased.
I think Envoy will be used
to deliver those use cases.
But as I was saying
before, I don't
think many people will end up
knowing that its Envoy that's
actually doing that.
They're going to use
integrated products.
So right now, from a
hybrid perspective,
obviously, we're going to
have years of people who have
on-prem, or in multiple clouds.
But over time, I
think we're going
to move to hosted Kubernetes.
And then from there we're going
to move to hosted function
platforms.
And it's going to
be a slow iteration,
but we just keep adding
more abstractions,
and hopefully every year
people will have to deal less
with infrastructure.
ANNA BERENBERG: I
probably want to talk
about an even higher
level of abstraction.
I think in three
years, maybe in five,
people stop configuring system
as they are today via APIs,
via these YAML files, and
everything, because we need
to not make the
service owners to be
having PhD in provisioning.
So all we want to do
is actually to move
towards intent-driven
configuration,
where the service can be
described into intents.
Do you want to
have a service with
latency-optimized to
optimized perceived
user latency from the user to
the front-end overall serving?
Or the other one, do you want
to have cost-optimized service,
or do you want to optimize
towards transferring less date
are over wire, or
something else?
These are the configurations
that will internally translate
into write configuration.
Because, today with
the hundreds of knobs,
even with your best intent you
may not end up with the intent
you want to have.
So we need to be able to
express intent very clearly
in a high level and
translate it internally.
And the second
thing, I think it's
super important to stop
thinking about each microservice
separately.
We need to start thinking
about overall deployment
and how to have
configuration policies that
apply to overall deployment,
how to provide consistency
and coherency to make sure
that if you're talking
about security policies, you
don't have to go and configure
on each of 180 microservices.
All you have to say, I'm
going to provision it one way,
and then it's
going to understand
how to apply it to everywhere
in the different ones,
however service is deployed.
And then you can link it into
some recommendation engine
that that can say,
oh, my god, you
didn't provision
something somewhere,
or you have vulnerability
about security.
Or, in general, it can look at
the deployment, and can say,
you can do better.
Right?
That's I think where we want
to be in three, five years.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So I
think with that we come
to a close of this session.
Matt and Ann will be here,
probably outside the room.
So feel free to reach out.
The nice thing
is, a lot of these
are very new technologies,
and the reason
we are talking
about them so early
is because we do
want each one of you
to influence these technologies.
And we added a set
of features that we
thought were table stakes.
But I'm sure there are a lot
more features that you need
on your end to make
this just be the tool
to make your hybrid and
multicloud deployments
seamless.
So with that, thank
you, folks for coming.
And feel free to talk
to our two people
and ask them all
the tough questions.
Thank you everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]